>>> JUST IN TO CNN, THE JANUARY
6 SELECT COMMITTEE HAS NEW
RECEIVED TWO YEARS WORTH OF TEXT
MESSAGES FROM RIGHT-WING
CONSPIRACY THEORIST ALEX JONES.
THESE FIRST CAME TO LIGHT WHEN
JONES' LEGAL TEAM MISTAKENLY
HANDED THEM OVER TO THE
PLAINTIFFS IN HIS DEFAMATION
TRIAL.
THAT'S WHEN CONGRESS GOT WISE TO
THE MESSAGES.
LET'S GET RIGHT TO OLIVER DARCY
WHO'S HERE WITH ME.
SO EXPLAIN HOW THEY GOT THESE
TEXTS.
>> THEY CAME TO LIGHT DURING
THAT DEFAMATION TRIAL LAST WEEK.
AT THE TIME THE ATTORNEY
REPRESENTING THE SANDY HOOK
PARENTS SAID AFTER HE DISCLOSED
HE OBTAINED THESE MESSAGES, THE
COMMITTEE EXPRESSED INTEREST IN
WANTING THEM.
HE WAS INCLINED TO TURN THEM
OVER BARRING A RULING FROM THE
JUDGE THAT PREVENTED HIM FROM
DOING SO.
ON FRIDAY THE JUDGE SAID SHE WAS
NOT GOING TO STAND IN THE WAY
BETWEEN CONGRESS AND THE TEXT
MESSAGES.
NOW WE'RE LEARNING THAT THEY
HAVE BEEN TURNED OVER BY THE
SANDY HOOK PLAINTIFF TEAM TO THE
JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE.
>> WHY DID THEY WANT THESE TEXT
MESSAGES?
TALK TO US ABOUT ALEX JONES'
ROLE POTENTIALLY IN THE EVENTS
AROUND JANUARY 6th.
>> YEAH, THEY'RE VERY INTERESTED
IN ALEX JONES.
THIS IS BECAUSE HE WAS AT THE
CAPITOL ON JANUARY 6th.
HE WAS SEEN ON CAMERA RILING UP
PROTESTERS.
HE WAS A BIG PERSON PUSHING THE
IDEA THAT THE ELECTION WAS
POTENTIALLY STOLEN FROM TRUMP.
OBVIOUSLY THAT'S NOT TRUE.
AND SO THE COMMITTEE HAS
EXPRESSED SIGNIFICANT INTEREST
IN TALKING TO ALEX JONES.
THEY ACTUALLY DID TALK TO HIM
BUT HE SAID ON HIS SHOW THAT HE
CLAIMED THE FIFTH MORE THAN 100
TIMES.
NOW THEY'RE GOING TO SEE THOSE
TEXT MESSAGES AND I THINK A LOT
MORE WILL BE ILLUMINATED TO THEM
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY JONES WAS NOT
COOPERATING WITH THE COMMITTEE.
>> WE DON'T KNOW WHAT WAS IN
THOSE TEXT MESSAGES, BUT DO WE
KNOW WHO HE WAS PERHAPS TEXTING
WITH?
>> WE DON'T KNOW ANYTHING REALLY
OUTSIDE OF THE FACT THAT THOSE
HAVE BEEN TURNED OVER TO THE
JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE.
BUT, YOU KNOW, ALEX JONES IS A
MAJOR STAR IN RIGHT-WING MEDIA,
SO IT WOULD NOT BE SURPRISING IF
THERE ARE TEXT MESSAGES BETWEEN
HIM AND TOP PLAYERS IN THAT
WORLD, IN TRUMP'S ORBIT.
HE WOULD BOAST THAT HE DID KNOW
ABOUT INNER WORKINGS OF THE
WHITE HOUSE AND WHAT WAS GOING
TO BE HAPPENING.
SO IT'S VERY LIKELY, EVEN
POSSIBLE THAT HE HAD SOME
CONTACT WITH TRUMP'S ORBIT.
WE'LL FIND OUT MORE COMING UP.
>> WE'LL SEE IF THERE ARE ANY
NEW REVELATIONS, ESPECIALLY AS
THEY RETURN IN SEPTEMBER AND
POTENTIALLY HAVE MORE HEARINGS,
THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE.
OLIVER DARCY, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.